[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to start the first chapter
on kinematics
and before we actually start
the technical discussions uh
i believe that this chapter that is the
name of this chapter will be familiar
with
familiar to both the mechanical guys uh
the mechanical students and the
manufacturing students from their
earlier courses on fluid mechanics and
thermo fit science
and the underlying philosophy that we
are going to follow while covering
kinematics in our current course of
mechanics of solids
will be exactly the same as in treat
mechanics and thermophilic science
meaning that we are going to
be slowly concerned with the way that
the motion is described or the
deformation is described
in this chapter and we are not at all
going to be bothered
with the way that that motion is brought
about meaning that we are not going to
be concerned with the forces the dogs
and the gender and in general the
loadings that are
that the bodies are being subjected to
without any further ado
let us begin our uh study of kinematics
so the first section we're going to
cover is
called deformation
and displacement
so in this section
we'll focus our attention on developing
a very general mathematical theory
or framework by which we can describe
the deformation in the displacement
of a general three-dimensional body so
the first thing that we are going to
consider is a general three-dimensional
body
so like this
the general three-dimensional body and
this will call to be in the initial or
the undeformed state
so this is the undeformed state
now under some loading which we do not
care about within the ambit of this
chapter
this three-dimensional body will undergo
some deformation
and it will end up in this final
or current configuration so this is how
it
responds please note that there is no
restriction
as to whether the volume will be
preserved
or any such notion or now it is
completely general the volume can change
the shape can change it can go from one
place to another
no restriction at all so this will be
our current state
now in order to describe to precisely
mathematically describe the deformation
what we are going to consider is a
generic point within this body
so this is a generic point within the
body
and let it be denoted by the capital
letter t
correspondingly when this body
is deforming from the undeformed to the
current state
depicted by this arrow the material
point p
will end up let's say here
and in this current state it will be
depicted
by the letter p with a dash
so the the dash or the prime uh this
here
it represents the position of
of the same material point which was
this
now in order to mathematically describe
this we need uh
first of all to set up our coordinate
axis so
so instead of calling this as x y z
which we are usually
familiar with uh
what we are going to do is we are going
to call this as capital x1
capital x2 and capital x3
in order to keep the mathematical
description as general as possible
now you understand that this x1 x2 and
x3
are like the scalar components of uh
it will help us to set up the scalar
components of a position vector
so the position vector of the point p
with reference to this coordinate axis
will be given
by this capital x vector
whose components we understand will be
x1 x2 and x3
please note that this is in the
undeformed state
and in this undeformed state uh the
position vector is given by the capital
x letter correspondingly
when this deforms and comes here for
this p dash
point which is basically the same point
but in the
current state the position vector again
with reference to this coordinate axis
it will be given by the small x
so this is how we represent it now
please note
that this position vector x is very much
dependent
on the initial position vector in this
configuration or in this undeformed
state
so the values that this
this small x1 x2 and x3 can take this
will be very much dependent
on the values of the capital x1 x2 and
x3
and in general it will also be a
function of the time
at which we are taking this particular
picture
so for our mathematical representation
what we
say is
the x1
is a function of all the scalar
components
x 1 capital x 1 capital x 2 and capital
x 3
as well as of the time t
the scalar component x small x 2
is again a function of all the scalar
components
capital x 1 capital x 2 and capital x 3
in the undeformed state and similarly
the third component
x small x 3 is again a function of
all the scalar components capital x 1
capital x and capital x 3
as well as time in the undeformed state
so this
three pieces of information it is
together depicted
in a compact form
to this vector representation
all right now in index notation
this will be depicted by x
i
x i
function of x j
comma t now uh
in every class that i teach this is
always a little bit of a confusion among
the students
that why perhaps we are not using the
same index i here
well uh there are two reasons here
uh first of all is that suppose if we
were to write i
it gives us a sort of wrong impression
it may give us a sort of wrong
impression that perhaps the
ith component of the position vector
in the current state it perhaps depends
only on the i-th
component of the initial position vector
and that would be a wrong notion
because actually it is dependent on all
the three
components capital x 1 x 2 and x 3 as we
have
written out explicitly here furthermore
if you're a little bit familiar with
index notation but not too familiar then
there
might arise some sort of a wrong
impression that
perhaps in some way some kind of
repeated index is happening here because
this is
small x and then there's a capital x i
and perhaps it denotes some kind of a
summation
and that would be again completely wrong
in order to avoid all those confusions
or
possibilities of misrepresentations uh
misinterpretations
of we keep these two indices separate
all right so the next uh the plan for
uh our next discussion is to go on to
definition
of the displacement so that will do in
the next part of our lecture
thank you